welcome to another Dr Sadler's honest
book reviews the book that we're looking
at today is kind of an unusual one and I
will say that it was a gift that was
sent to me by my colleague Simon Drew so
it is called the poet and the sage a
journey beyond the distant Hills and so
I'll be talking about all sorts of ins
and outs of this this series is one
that's oriented primarily to philosophy
and what we've got here is a book of
philosophy very much in the framework a
narrative framework of story and poetry
so you know the the book is really well
aptly named poet and Sage poetry and
wisdom so let's jump into the review
I always like to begin by talking about
three big asses style structure and
summary so why don't we start this time
with style right so I mentioned that
it's a book of poetry and it it
certainly is in significant Parts the
rest of it is numbered paragraphs like
you see here so it's pros of a certain
sort and lots and lots of poetry I'll
also mention as well that it is a book
whose format itself it's physical format
is supposed to be aesthetically pleasing
so you notice this really nice cover
image and then when you look inside I
mean this is kind of old fashioned old
timey book design right some beautiful
image injury there and on the back part
the book itself is really quite nice you
know it's even got this great little
reading ribbon
um so it's it's essentially you know
laid out like an old timey
um book of of poetry and and or uh prose
and you know to summarize it a little
bit we could say that it falls into the
genre of nomic poetry and literature
where it's essentially supposed to be
teaching you something by means of
hearing about by reading about by
observing the development of one of the
main characters the poet in this story
so
um the style for it you know a lot of it
is actually written in quatrains that
you know four
um or verse stanzas and so I'll just
read you a little bit of it right now
you can get a sense of it this is from
one of the the sections that we're going
to talk about later
um black smoke rose up into the sky from
the dragon's Bleak insistence that her
power would soon befall them and would
threaten their existence and as the sun
sank lower far beyond the distant Hills
they could see there'd be no mercy for a
monster only kills and so you know
there's some Rhythm to it some meter as
we say it's not you know consistent in
the uh metrical scheme but but it is
rhyming right so
we have you know a b a b throughout most
of it and then a lot of it is this uh
narrative that is in these fairly short
numbered uh paragraphs I'll give you a
read a little bit more of this this is
from the very beginning the poet spent
most of his time in his village cabin
sitting listening and searching for
anything to distract him from the truth
everything was a distraction to the poet
for he was a fool and him nothing on the
Earth was put to good use and he was as
a tree which had grown Wayward under the
pressure of the strong Valley winds he
had not yet received the same insight as
his father the holy prophet for though
he had acquired a natural way with words
he did not value his gift and he
believed himself to be sufficient and he
was prideful and he believed that he
knew the way the holy prophet had cared
for the people of the village and they
had cared for him in return they were
better for each other for he always
spoke the truth as he saw it and the
people of the village were Guided by the
truth that he spoke and they saw that
the words he spoke were brought into
being it goes on from there but you get
a sense of what the style of the the
work is like it's a kind of old-timey
there's a lot you you don't actually get
it in this but you do get it in plenty
of others you know for example in this
section here of the tree there's a lot
of v's and vows and ye's in it as well
right truth thou hath seen righteous
poet for if thou would would firmly tie
thine understanding to me and If thy
culture would be tied to thee then
together we shall guide thy culture and
thou will taste Wilt Taste of alignment
which is eternal life and the people of
thy Village will taste of alignment and
thou Wilt run and play in the canopy
above thee which doth spread its lofty
branches far throughout space and time
and thou Wilt feel the warmth of the Sun
which doth sustain the tree and which
doth sustain thee right so a lot of that
sort of old-timey archaic language being
used here I think to try to create a
certain effect so
um what is the summary of this I
mentioned this is essentially like a
learning kind of narrative
well we could call it a building's Roman
right where it's about the development
the education of a younger person
eventually becoming something and really
that's what a lot of the story is about
we begin with a poet who's kind of a
jerk at the start as we see who's got a
father who you know had been you know a
great prophet very important to the
village and then he has all sorts of
interesting encounters gradually
develops wisdom step by step by step
begins uh teaching and some of the
people of the village accept his
teachings find them useful a lot of the
teachings turn out to be things that
were gleaning from other wisdom
literature from philosophy as we'll
discuss in a bit and some of the other
villagers don't like what he's doing and
they react against him and eventually is
going to lead to a conclusion where and
I'm going to give you a spoiler here so
if you don't like spoilers shut your
ears he's going to get killed right but
it won't be terrible because he lives on
in many other ways so that's that's a
summary and and what we're seeing in
this work is going through all of this
and you know it's arranged into some
short chapters you could sit down and
probably read this entire thing through
in an afternoon and you could let
yourself linger over it so it's got a
prologue and then you know an initial
poem and then you know another poem the
call and then we get to the poet himself
the poet has a dream we go to the
distant Hills to the tree and we go on
and on and on there's even a section
called the revelations which has a
number of interesting teachings then we
go B beyond the distant Hills let his
wisdom flow and then we get to this is
end where
um uh you know he's
going to be the final communion right
and the golden way and then uh the final
words of the poet himself and a Soul's
release and that's you know that's it
and the book itself 149 Pages
um there's a couple finishing poems
Comes the Night thy will be done
actually let's let's just read that that
one because again it gives you a good
sense of what's going on walk in lofty
Woodlands look too distant stars eat
from ancient fig trees drink from
flowing reservoirs spread thy Roots yet
deeper reach thy branches to the sky for
the kingdom now awaits you and thy Soul
must be aligned and know that thou art
everything and nothing and the one and
know that thou doth serve his will which
cannot not be done so you know a little
bit of again gnomic right teaching
wisdom teaching understanding poetry so
those are the style structure summary of
this work
all right so what are the main points or
ideas there's there's quite a few I
think we should talk first about the
plot The Narrative structure of what's
going on in here and so we have a
village that has been Guided by the
poet's dad the holy prophet and the
villagers are you know for the most part
a bunch of rum Dums you know they have
the wrong sorts of priorities it's a
good thing they had the holy prophet to
help straighten them out because they
value the wrong things you know like uh
money and pleasure and security and all
these sorts of of things so the poet
himself as we see I mentioned a little
bit earlier is kind of a good for
nothing at the beginning but he is going
to have a successive set of encounters
with some other important characters who
are going to eventually guide him into
the way and some of this will come
through actual encounters some of this
will happen through dreams so he's going
to meet a teacher within this dream he's
going to meet a Seer he's going to meet
a sage a Seer is somebody who you know
can see beyond the the normal things
that we can and perhaps even predict the
future a sage of course is the legendary
wise person and you know they're they're
all in here and and the poet goes back
and forth between them at different
points and is learning from them through
dialogue through discussion through
having things being revealed to him now
one of the absolutely most Central
points you heard me mention that word
alignment that gets used a lot in this
and I kind of think you know given uh
Simon Drew's connection with stoicism
and a lot of different uh organizations
involved in it that alignment is
supposed to be sort of a different word
word choice for harmony or being in
accordance with it that's kind of a cool
idea I mean it crops up I would say I'm
like at least every third page gets
discussed over and over and over again
and so alignment with what well with the
logos that gets also mentioned an awful
lot gets mentioned in relation to the
one capitalized oftentimes in all caps
and there's this contrast between like
grasping these things in genuine wisdom
and being like a sleeper or a dreamer
like those those villagers or like the
poet can be at different points so this
is a basic thematic of the work you know
we're moving from not understanding
things to understanding things and
the poet himself is going to teach to
the villagers as time goes on and the
teaching gets better and better as the
poet gets better and better so you know
here's an example right here the the
people of the village spoke to one
another about the poem which the poet
recited on to them in the Village Square
for some had heard with italics and some
had seen and some had felt but many
heard him not though they wish to hear
him the poet prepared to speak again and
he wished to wake more from their dreams
he wished to show them
eternity even that they might know the
truth which he spake and he stood again
in the Village Square and he spoke on to
the people saying the body is a river
the soul a dream and Mist a timely
observation from a sage within my midst
but do I dare to wonder do I dare to see
do I dare to question what this Sage
would teach to me or will I watch it
flow right through one ear and out the
next well I settle for a life wherein my
soul remains perplexed will I value not
my freedom will my eyes not care to look
could these words be providential or
just some scribblings in a book and you
get the idea of of what's going on there
he's sort of like leading them into his
thinking and so you know what is the
book essentially about how the poet is
able to develop and then articulate
true wisdom and self-knowledge and even
the virtues there's some Mansion a
little bit later on in one of the poems
about the four cardinal stoic virtues
and you know in the narrative the the
um
the poet is going to be tried and
eventually he'll be executed while he's
still engaged in teaching by people of
the village why just like Socrates they
didn't truly understand his message and
what he was trying to you know lead them
into and they were afraid of him or they
found themselves angry at him but this
isn't the total loss because death is
not the end you know another uh key
teaching that we find in here that's
kind of cool I think this fits in with
the alignment thing and the logos and
the one is that you know everything has
its place and its purpose it's just up
to us to figure out what those are and
it brings in nature and culture and how
we bring the two of them together you
know so it's
pretty interesting
reworkings of classic teachings I think
that we we find here there's also you
know this theme uh which again very
common in a lot of ancient philosophy
and religious
um thinking that
um you know while there's this whole
section called despise the flesh right
so the body the flesh
um and you know the poet gets prideful
uh believing the sage to be his own
believing he'd become the master of the
sage that he did not move by with the
will of the sage but his own will and he
wandered off the path of alignment and
then the sage tells them though Sage
reveals some wisdom and says
this is thy way Thou Art Bound by the
flesh whereas I am not and thou art as
nature is for thou doth turn this way in
that way and thine aim has been
corrupted and thy Soul doth fall even
with thy flesh and thy faith in my
direction has waned right
um and he's got this dream where he's
drinking from his hands from the murky
water he's crawling as a lizard crawls
and he was in filth and he was filth
right so there's this kind of let's get
away from too much dependence on the
body so there's a lot of different
interesting teachings main points in
this that I think are uh provocative
perhaps well worth exploring
um I I don't think I need to say too
much more about the main ideas of the
work you probably get that from what I
have already conveyed to you so now
let's talk about good points of the work
so what did I find good about the work I
mean first of all as I mentioned already
as an object it's a very beautiful
little book a lot of care and thought
and
time has gone into the production of
this object and I I think this is very
nice right there's even like uh on the
inside leaves some poetry there you know
I'll just read this to you may all who
read these Works be guided even that
they may see and hear and feel and know
right which is a reference to one of the
passages we discussed already and then
it's got you know a little blurb about
the author here so this is very
aesthetically put together very pleasing
in that sense
um you know the first idea of it the
story that's being told it's kind of a
cool story I I would say on
uh early on we get this mission that is
being discussed which
I think is quite worthwhile right how do
we know
what the right path in life is that's
what this is exploring right
um how do we get away from like he says
Those Who stuff their minds and labor by
their hands who are not aligned who are
judging nevertheless and all that this
is kind of a good idea the ideal of
alignment it's not just being
invoked it's being explored to some
degree so I think that's you know
something that is worth our thinking
about through the medium of this book I
I will also say that you know what Simon
drew it has his poet grappling with here
and some of the others like the sage or
you know the teacher
our fundamental existential questions
that remain unavoidable for us human
beings right so there's this great
passage in the dream this is Section
Five
he says uh
teacher I hope thy prophecy would be
untrue so I listen not I sat by the pond
I watched as many walked in I saw men
women children families of many
generations and more multitudes walking
into the pond none came out I wept and I
was in Despair and I did nothing then
from among the multitudes I beheld there
was a girl who smiled and she appeared
to be the same girl who had saved me
from the murky depths right so kind of a
wisdom Bearer right and and he goes on
and he says and then I saw she did walk
into the pond even with the multitudes
this was a thorn to my heart for she
appeared not to know she had been in
this place of Filth before right so
we're seeing like many of us grapple
with what is being discussed here saying
the procession of people going on with
their lives and it seems meaningless it
seems like it's a screw-up right in in
many respects how do we deal with that
how do we think or feel or find our way
out out of that
um I I kind of like that section which
deals with the pridefulness on the part
of the poet
um
where the sage says to the poet the sage
was angered by the poet's arrogance he
spoke to the poet directly and said
aren't thou so gluttonous that thou hath
left nothing for me thou hath surely
seen the roots of the cosmos that they
Bend and twist and that they bring about
all things but hath thou forgotten how
these things which were once hidden have
been revealed onto thee for I am with
thee and thou art within me and we are
as the light of the cosmos and as the
caretakers of the people in thy Village
and even as the caretakers of Eternity
have I revealed this wisdom onto thee
that thou might sit upon thy throne and
bask in thine own Glory I warn thee that
it is not for this reason I have
revealed such things for this wisdom
belongeth not to thee for at one moment
it is with thee and at the next that is
taken from thee so he's saying don't be
so prideful so selfish egotistical and
that's that's a good point I would say
there's also a lot of nice natural
imagery that Simon Drew is working with
in this you know I would say I brought
up that connection between nature and
culture and the Poetry is exploring both
of these and so was the uh discussions
between people I also say you know Drew
has a good sense for and capacity to
depict all these different emotional
states all these different affects It's
Not A Treatise of you know how to become
wise as such it's it's an exploration as
I mentioned existential conditions
existential Solutions on the part of the
poet as well so there's you know some
quite a few things to recommend this
little volume if you're into this sort
of thing
are there any features of this book that
I find problematic if not you know
necessarily bad yeah there's there's
always going to be
complaints that you can raise
particularly when it comes to poetry you
know the appreciation of poetry is
inherently subjective
um I'm not a huge fan of this I mean I I
enjoy the thinking through the
sentiments and the thoughts that are
involved I don't find it to be really
wonderful as poetry and I suppose that's
in part because maybe I'm a bit of a
stick in the mud but um the you know it
doesn't it has end rhyme but it doesn't
really have meter that's consistent in
it I also do find the style leaves me a
bit cold and I think that's in part
because of the the thou Vine stuff which
not only is
I kind of feel unnecessary it's it's
kind of an attempt to make it archaic
when it doesn't need to be
but it's also inconsistent so you know
one of the passages that I read to you
should have used Vine in both uh
descriptors as the possessive of
something but use thy and thine and I I
just you know
I I have a hard time with that as well
as the constantly addressing people in
the the uh plural as ye you know
um
some of the language I mean some people
might actually enjoy that quite a bit
low righteous poet if thou which trust
in me completely then thy Soul shall be
filled from its bondage and thy body
shall be no prison but it shall be as a
holy Temple I mean for me that's just
kind of old-timey language for the sake
of making it sound cooler but I you know
again very very subjective isn't it
um there's a lot of stoic doctrines
unsurprisingly uh since as I mentioned
Drew is involved with the modern Stark
movement that are woven in and kind of
reworked but there's not a lot of real
exploration or explanation of them it's
more like hitting on them sort of like
in show tunes when there's like a little
short passage and a medley that invokes
this tune without really going into it
so you're not gonna I mean you'll you'll
you'll be able to recognize those in
this but you're not going to learn an
awful lot from their re-workings in this
every once in a while there's some weird
word choices that make you uh pause for
a moment for example there's and this
could just be a typo
yolk like the egg yolk for yolk as in
the thing that you put on yourself right
and so maybe it could have used a little
bit of
other eyes for editing or something like
that the Poetry can sometimes feel a
little bit forced
which I guess is okay for teaching
poetry but
um sometimes you read it and you're like
yeah okay that one that one didn't come
off I'll just give you an example of
um one line and the teachers and
philosophers who saw the world as
Skeptics all did laugh and mock the
people for their dream was dialectics
okay you know that's
it's not terrible but it ain't great
it's somewhere in between and you know
there's um
there's quite a few of those and there
are sometimes some really great stanzas
though too as well so you know
um they're they're perhaps balanced with
each other on that
um there's another interesting section
that I I kind of didn't buy and this is
the section of Revelations
um by the it's a whole chapter the
revelations right the poet had retired
to his cabin for the evening he went
about preparing to commune with the sage
um
an evening storm rolled in from the East
and a soft rains fell on the dry planes
the sage whispered quiet words into the
poet's soul saying wise poet hear these
words I shall reveal unto thee and allow
me to guide thy quill even that thou
might record the revelations of in all
caps the one and that's essentially what
this chapter is and
you know it's one of those things where
if you've seen a lot of this kind of
the thou you know
talking about the universe as a whole it
reminds me of like uh parts of
Nietzsche's thus books are thustra or
kalheel gibran's the prophet
um and you know maybe there's something
to be gained from this
um I found it kind of you know like a
mishmash of of stuff sometimes there's
some interesting things you know
for example in section four the mother
knocks at the door wilt thou let her
enter wilt thou let her see the naked
even as thou began in the garden the
father knocks at thy door wilt thou show
him fine Hospitality will thou now meet
with him even that thou might know him
the son knocks at the door he is weary
and famished from his travels wilt thou
prepare him a meal wilt thou give him
drink wilt thou give him rest from his
wandering so you know nice holy family
there love thy mother mother honor thy
father know thyself oh you're the son
see worship me even the way the logos
and the one
um so you know some interesting stuff
there but I I don't know I find it kind
of
unnecessary and unconvincing but maybe
maybe others would enjoy it so those are
my criticisms of the work
all right final thoughts so if you are
into this kind of literature let's call
it wisdom
conveying poetry and prose you know
another one that that sort of comes to
mind is Hermann has the Siddhartha right
um well then you probably want to get
your hands on this it's certainly a
reworking of that theme there are parts
of Drew's writings that really shine
forth it can be kind of fun to sit down
and and think about it right
um and it is a beautiful volume as I've
mentioned it might be kind of cool to
have it and take it around just for that
you maybe you should get it I do want to
say that I really appreciate
um Simon sending it to me uh you know
it's a you see this little sort of like
it's not quite a dedication but sort of
uh you know
personalization of it so I have to
acknowledge my my gratitude for that and
that that's just where I'll end you know
it's an interesting little book maybe
you'd like it maybe not but if you have
the opportunity to give it a shot maybe
you should